danger danger danger warning warning
warning
[Musique]
je suis content que l'état se mêle de
notre liberté nous sommes au coeur d'une
liberté qui n'appartient pas au pouvoir
exécutif
c'est la liberté de dire et le droit de
savoir le seul arbitre c'est le jus
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
cette loi sur les fausses nouvelles
notamment en période électorale bien je
vais vous donner un exemple
une fois voté cette loi elle va
peut-être un jour ou l'autre être
utilisé contre des journaux indépendants
comme mediapart
quand est ce que mediapart obtient le
document les biens attestant du
financement de la campagne électorale de
sarkozy en 2007
entre les deux tours de la
présidentielle de 2012 en pleine
campagne électorale
nous n'avons pas de gestion partisane de
nos informations donc nous publions
quand ces prêts nous publions le samedi
qui précède le second tour monsieur
sarkozy nous tombe dessus il dit fausses
nouvelles
il dit faux et usage de faux il
n'utilise pas larmes qui est celle de la
loi démocratique la loi de 1881 nous
poursuivent à la loyale en diffamation
on aurait amené tous les éléments et on
aurait vu que nous avions de quoi
prouver ce que nous inventions
donc ils contournent en renforçant avec
ses toits on va permettent de contourner
on va permettre demain de dire a préféré
pour fausses nouvelles alors bien sûr le
pouvoir nous dit on va mettre une
condition c'est que ce soit des moteurs
genre une campagne d'intoxication venue
d'une attaque de l'étranger mais une
info de telle importance de mediapart
elle est diffusée partout
elle est reprise partout et donc on va
nous dire un juge d'un tribunal en
référé sous une pression politique
partisane sous la pression du pouvoir
exécutif avec une nouvelle loi qui sort
du droit de la presse qui sort de la loi
de 1881 eh bien on va venir nous dire ah
c'était une fausse nouvelle vous ne
pouviez pas la diffuser à ce moment là
on va tuer la nouvelle qui dérange la
liberté la liberté n'a pas besoin que
l'état s'en mêle